dishes on her eyebrow raising New York
City dinner with disgraced U.S ex
Governor Cuomo Donald Trump's former
political advisor insisted Tuesday there
was no uh Amor in the air as she had a
private late night meal with disgrace
former New York Governor Andrew Cuomo at
a famous Upper East Side Italian
restaurant Italians prefer eating to
zoom we would have invited his brother
Christopher but it's unclear that he
it's uh unclear that he eats carbs uh
Cuomo is reporting uh currently single
while the 55 year old Conway is married
to attorney and vocal Trump critic
George Conway nothing romantic I've
known Como family for decades Conway
said that dinner dinners menu for
discussion included how they both had
podcasts with same company Quake media
and talk of various political issues on
which they could find Common Ground like
I that just like just what a random
crazy like besides them they're on the
same podcast company no I have an
opinion what
go with me here okay I think uh Trump is
interviewing candidates for VP he
started looking at Kanye all right
that's as crazy as it gets these days
okay he brought his boy Nick Fuentes now
he's like all right who shocks the
system as much as anybody these days
Andrew Cuomo I don't know there's a
trump play here something's telling me
kellyanne Conway is still in touch with
Trump for sure she was his best flag
carrier no doubt for sure and believe me
the topic of trump did come up in this
conversation at dinner and I don't know
I think Trump is still looking for a VP
and if there's anything that Trump likes
it's being in the headlines and you know
of kellyanne Conway and Cuomo the
disgraced
handsy touchy Governor Cuomo or having a
meal together you know Trump's name was
brought up crazy opinion call it what it
is but I don't know wow Trump's done
crazier things
I I I don't know how to read it or it's
just a couple folks that run in
political circles that have a respect
for each other perhaps that just grab
dinner over the holidays they're not
dumb if there was really something
romantic going on they're not going to
get seen at a restaurant like this
neither one of them is dumb especially
what he's been through and what she's
been through with George I think there's
a nothing Burger I think it was a couple
of operatives having a discussion I
think Cuomo is far far far from the
orbit of who could be you know VP
that's what I think I think it's a
nothing Burger I think it's a Adam's
fantasy I think yeah Adam wants to vote
for Trump but only if Cuomo is
very weird people and videos that's the
way he would be open to the idea yeah I
don't know if I think much of it by the
way but at the same time is she wearing
a skirt
well she's looking like a raccoon I
don't know what she's wearing and uh you
know I don't know I have a photo of her
but I'm a big fan of this of her she's a
talent man there's there's certain
people you want to have on your side
she's one of them so who needs this
picture more sheer him he does no
question about it so 90 10. so let me
tell you
did he ask her hey can we go out to
dinner I just want to go out to dinner I
want to get a little a little buzz in
the Press I need to do some things I'm
trying to no you know I don't think so
Cuomo is not gonna go quietly into that
good night there's he's there's gonna be
a Revival at some point I mean okay he's
not just gonna but yeah I'm just curious
I'm out and retired he's
he's we have not seen the law the the
last of the cuomos right I mean his
brother is back doing some podcasts that
I don't know who's watching it but I
mean dude is he is he I know how many
women came forward is he going to get in
trouble I mean there's no joke he's a
he's a politician so he's not going to
go to jail but how many how many
staffers came out and said that he was
sexually harassing and groping them was
there a number enough to win a big
election baby so what all the craziness
taking place I believe future looks
bright if you believe future looks
bright get your latest Future looks
bright hat of valuetainment it says
future looks bright here future looks
bright here we got him in white we got
them in Black we got them in red our
black on black sold out these are about
to sell out if you haven't ordered one
yet we had a person in Michigan but one
then he bought three then when those
three people wore it in the office they
had to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hat
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody's saying future
look spread toward your future looks
bright hat click over here and to watch
the entire podcast click here take care
everybody
[Music]